[Musique]
la belle marie n'gbo
je vais venir de là que je viens c'est à
dire du peuple quand on peut prendre
oprean ce n'est pas une présidentielle
c'est un jeu de massacre
création originale barreaux noirs saison
3 bientôt et seulement sur canal+
je suis venu ici pour être à l'abri du
danger mais on n'est jamais à l'abri du
passé aidez moi s'il vous plaît ce
supporter vie nous avons l'obligation
d'enquêter du genou n'existe pas
jean-luc rentrez chez vous
je dois absolument l'aider vous voulez
vraiment repartir dans le froid
plus que jamais
le passé décrit
[Musique]
mais c'est à nous que revient d'écrire
les chapitres futur
merci de ne pas avoir tenté de me
dissuader de partir je ne ferai pas une
bêtise pareille
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que juan ne nous dit pas
adieu mais un au revoir
entouré de tous ses proches et des gens
qu'il aime notre adolescence a vraiment
été atrocement pour faire ce qu'on
aurait dû faire depuis 15 ans une
révolution je veux que vous vous rendiez
à la réunion des anciens élèves et que
vous pensiez mes cendres sur 6 ha le jeu
vous filmez vous partagiez je veux que
le monde sache qu'il faut plus me faire
chier la réunion élite dans deux
semaines on a quoi 30 followers à nous
trois réunis c'est pour ça qu'on va
avoir besoin d'être quelqu'un qui est
dans le guen un proche même de la
famille assez votre frère il fait quoi
c'est une bouse de télé réalité où ils
sont beaux ils ont espoir n'a qu'à
demander à ton frère
vous avez des looks de merde vous êtes
norbourg vous êtes chiant on va vous
trouver des personnalités de cette
agréable
t'es sûr vous êtes parfait encore des
gens qui aiment le dire combien c'est
comme le plastique
apprenez à sortir vos piques sans
prévenir et vos vies a lancé mario sa
carte vous avez foutu
[Musique]
ce n'est pas fort bordel [ __ ] tu
allais vraiment senti un tamis semeta
forcément viens viens le leader flamand
[Musique]
on va à l'école directement ou alors le
petit déjeuner
kaori un chapeau ne crois pas que
j'étais pas venu
gâteau il
les enfants sortaient de mon jardin
d'après ce que vous si je comprends bien
nous avons là la bombe 10,5
vous savez tous que c'est à lire pour la
première fois les burundais pourront
choisir librement leur président de la
république papa c'est quoi la différence
entre les hutus et les tutsis écoutent
ils n'ont pas le même mais la guerre
mais après les hutus let it is parce
qu'ils n'ont pas le même territoire
vingt six ans le même pays ils ont la
même langue et vont la même église
laisse pas pourquoi la ceiba cause de
leur nez si tu veux vivre ici tu seras
obligé de choisir cliquant ici choisit
pas tu vois pourquoi séparer la clé sont
2 émulateurs aucune pression
[Musique]
la gare a tout changé d'avis
et où tout
se protège page c'est dur
ja
[Musique]
à l'étude
[Applaudissements]
bach
la baisse est mort trois marques
[Musique]
oui en effet
ni à quoi là au milieu personne ne le
sait vraiment personne n'est allé aussi
loin au nord mais certains pensent dur
comme fer que tous là où se trouve une
terre qui attend d'être découverte
le jeune et très prometteur explorateur
norvégien roald amundsen ils préparent
tous une expédition
on a très peu de temps
[Musique]
nous sommes les plus d'une expédition
c'est une course avez vous déjà bravé le
froid arctique
vous nous avez laissé derrière à
l'abandon lors du retour à la base ou
n'abandonne pas ses hommes à mort
probable serait sur une autre planète
que ce ne serait pas différent et vous
avez la naïveté de croire que ça devrait
se faire sans risque
[Musique]
l'essor précieux sont ceux dont le
pouvoir des machinations et si puissants
qu'ils sont capables et des singes et
les demandes n'ont rien pour vous
exclusivement au pharo gbagbo est un
homme qui ne font jamais même au contact
des plus belles femmes de paris ou
d'imagés qui fait alors la piscine était
bonne j'ai fait partie fine et 7 a le
coeur ça fait bien longtemps qu'elle
explose et je ressens plus rien
maintenant amour c'est fini pour moi toi
une femme te quitte tut interdit l'amour
par un problème avec les chèques d'avril
avec le panache d'habitude les aime qui
entendent la voix tombe six films en
amoureux du mal que leurs cars explose
vous allez mourir tu comme tous les
autres tous tous ça fait mal au coeur
bon on peut jouer car outre quality qui
va exploser ce cas et cette fois pour
toujours vraiment ça fait l'amour je
compte de la joie à pic
j'ai tellement contente de vous faire
aucun des faits dommage que vous partiez
maintenant quand même parce que moi
j'étais immunisés si vous restez avec
non c'est trop risques et ouais
des marchés ciblés
le plein de voir sinon il va mourir
[ __ ] vous êtes complètement saoul sur
nos prises
elle est en train de vous tuer
chacun son pick-up
premier vol de l'a été
[Musique]
on